ganz deutschland debattiert über den
offenen brief der künstler ein
bundeskanzler olaf scholz soll
deutschland schwere waffen liefern an
die ukraine wird deutschland damit zur
kriegspartei und wie groß ist
tatsächlich die gefahr eines dritten
weltkrieges zu gast heute abend bei mir
politikwissenschaftlerin und autorin
ulrike groos sie hat sich bei corona
weit aus dem fenster gelehnt und sich
jetzt der warnung von alice schwarzer
vor einem dritten weltkrieg in folge der
waffenhilfe für die ukraine
angeschlossen anders sieht das publizist
henryk broder hält alice schwarzer für
naiv und fordert volle härte gegen den
aggressor mz politik redakteur alexander
kissler ist alice schwarzer dankbar dass
sie eine debatte angestoßen hat frauke
petry die frühere fdp-vorsitzende
kritisiert schwarz das brief scharf und
sagt putin lässt sich nur mit schwerem
waffeneinsatz stopp frau doro ich möchte
direkt mit ihnen ein intelligent
intellektuelle wie intelligent sind die
augen aber intellektuell wie alice
schwarzer ranga yogeshwar oder die tanne
haben diesen brief geschickt ein herrn
scholz und sie haben auch getwittert
dass die den brief vollumfänglich
unterstützen glauben sie denn nicht dass
das naiv ist also erst mal ich ihnen
auch unterschrieben wie weitere 170
tausend unterzeichner das ist ja
wirklich sozusagen richtig nach oben
gegangen ich glaube tatsächlich dass der
brief novelle ausgelöst hat und ich
stehe voll umfänglich zu den brief wie
ich getwittert habe warum weil wenn wir
auf dieses leid gucken von mario pohl
den krankenhäusern butscher und so
weiter dann kann ich nur sagen cicero
der ungerechteste frieden ist
besser als der gerechteste krieg ja und
wenn wir uns jetzt um dieses leid
bemühen diese bilder nicht haben wollen
dann müssen wir frieden machen frieden
machen frieden machen und damit anfangen
jede eskalation ist unvertretbar allein
die tatsache dass zum beispiel gabor
steingart heute morgen im prinzip einer
eskalation und auch eine nukleare
eskalation für kontrollierbar hält das
scheint mir so hanebüchen so absurd als
könnte man eine eskalation sozusagen
jetzt schon kontrolliert irgendwie
einpreisen dass ich nur sagen kann wie
viel leid wollen wir eigentlich noch
hoch skalieren um endlich frieden zu
machen und das ist die position glaube
ich dass brief ist und wir sollten nicht
übersehen und das hat der brief jahren
deutlich herausgearbeitet dass wenn wir
jetzt schwere waffen liefern dann ist
das auch noch völkerrecht wenn wir dann
auch noch ausbildung zu lassen an diesen
waffen de facto auch völkerrechtlich
sehr sehr strittig ob das nicht
tatsächlich dann auch ein grund wäre uns
eine motivation zu unterstellen dass wir
kriegsteilnehmer werden darum geht ja
die völkerrechtliche debatte dh wir
sollten alles tun von westlicher seite
wenn wir den frieden wollen dann sollten
wir alles tun motive zu geben und man
das letzte jungs ausschluss bedeuten die
ukraine soll sich ergeben ergeben also
die frage ist ja das habe ich glaube
schon der letzten sendung gesagt bei
ihnen vor zwei wochen das mir ist ja
überhaupt gar nicht klar was sind denn
überhaupt sozusagen die westlichen ziele
für die ukraine ja also wenn wir jetzt
mal ansetzen zusagen territoriale
integrität der ukraine ukraine in die eu
ukraine in die nato dann sind das völlig
unrealistische ziele also die ukraine
hat selten eine territoriale integrität
gehabt denn die verhandlungen in die eu
wurden 2014 de facto von ukrainischer
seite nicht angenommen das heißt wir
müssen uns doch mal überlegen was ist
eigentlich das strategische ziel was wir
erreichen wollen wofür wir jetzt eine
eskalation bereits in kauf zu nehmen
sind das scheint mir überhaupt nicht
klar und ich glaube wenn wir uns mal
genau angucken wo wir ich sag nochmal
cicero der ungerechteste frieden ist
besser als die gerechteste krieg wenn
wir sagen wir wollen den frieden dann
machen wir den morgen dann sagen wir
verhandlungen dann hört das
geschlachtete auf in wirtschaft und dann
wird es auf in mario pohl aber mit
schweren waffen und mit eskalation und
mit atomar werden wir im prinzip einen
einem eine martialisch strategie fahren
von der ich gar nicht weil sie ja
irgendjemand vor augen hat was das
bedeutet wir holen wir einmal frau petri
rein wenn sie jetzt frau genauso zu
hören sehen auch die gefahr eines
dritten weltkrieges und sollten wir
aufhören schwere waffen in die ukraine
zu liefern den wunsch der frei den kann
ich verstehen den teilen wollen ich
glaube dass da sind wir uns auch gar
eigentlich an diesem tisch und nicht nur
diesen tisch aber das was sie gerade
gesagt haben wir machen fliegen und
verhandeln das ist doch völlig
realitätsfern putin wird so nicht
verhandeln wir verstehen gar nicht
wichtig für ihn gibt es nur sieg oder
niederlage für ihn gibt es auch keine
verhandlungs partner auf augenhöhe mit
den ski wird er sich gar nicht treffen
das heißt wenn wir frieden wollen wenn
wir für die ukraine eine erträgliche
situation wollen ist die erste frage zu
stellen haben wer entscheidet was die
ukraine will ich glaube nicht dass wir
das entscheiden wir tun als deutsche und
europäer gut daran die ukraine an diese
entscheidung selbst überlassen und wie
viele opfer sie bringen wollen können
auch nicht wir für sie entscheiden wir
können nur entscheiden helfen wir die
überfallenen was nicht heißt dass sie
mit allen dingen die ukraine tut oder
auch getan hat in der vergangenheit
einverstanden sein müssen aber jetzt
gibt es nur die frage kampf oder
kapitulation es gibt keine verhandlungen
es gibt momentan auch keinen frieden mit
putin putin wird diese nur zustimmen
wenn eine lage gebracht wird in der für
ihn ersichtlich wird dass er ist nur
noch mit noch größerem aufwand und noch
größeren aufwand gewinnen kann das ist
nicht schön aber um schön geht's nicht
aber das ist kriegerische realität ob
wir wollen oder nicht aber was ist denn
das ziel ist das ziel dass wir sozusagen
einen feldzug gegen putin und russland
führen dass wir den krieg gewinnen wenn
ihr alle graf militärs sagen dass krieg
nicht überraschend also dass natürlich
ist auch klar aber wir entweder reden
wir jetzt darüber dass wir das gemetzel
in butter und mario pohl nicht mehr
sehen wollen und dann reden wir darüber
reden die
arbeit mache das fernsehen einfach
aussehen kann doch die ukraine was sie
wollen aber was wollen wir doch damals
anja 2014 zum beispiel gab es ja wenn
jetzt in zwei jahren aber es ist ja
schon wichtiger zu kontextualisierung ja
gesagt zu aktualisieren ukraine in die
eu ist ja eine dieser forderung die im
raum steht 2014 gab es das angebot von
wem wurde das abgelehnt aber die sind
erinnern warum helfen
angeschlagen sind
er sehe ich alle nacheinander ausrede
bruder sie
wunderbare edle ziele haben frau aber in
dem fall würde ich sagen müssen sich
eigentlich an putin richten es ist eine
absolute obszönität die sich aufhören an
dem opfer einer attacke zu appellieren
sich zu ergeben
damit der aggressor bestimmter grenzen
hält sie haben offenbar keine ahnung von
putin und der ukrainischen geschichte
anfangen der ukraine ist seit einer
weile ein souveräner staat es ist kein
deutsches general werner und es ist
keine aufgabe deutscher intellektueller
zu sagen was die ukraine sollen und was
sie nicht dürfen das hat der brief auch
gar nicht getaucht er genau die leute
sagen der privaten ukraine die sollen
selbstmord begehen weil sie nach dem
gemetzel nach ihm sehen ein dass schon
einer das nicht trennen sondern hatte
ich keine lesen aber er oder ich eine
sache eine kurze rückfrage nur ein herr
bruder der brief sagt ja nur ein leaders
die intellektuellen auch angst haben wie
ranga yogeshwar oder die in schwarzer
oder auch urige groß dass ein das ist
halt zu einem dritten weltkrieg führen
könnte ja okay das ist diese ja denn die
gefahr gibt es immer völlig unabhängig
davon was gerade in der ukraine passiert
zumal mit putin aber er ist größer
geworden nein ich glaube in die tasse
größe geworden ist größer geworden ist
nur ihre angst und ihre anpassung eines
zur resignation zusammen was sie machen
sollen sie haben offenbar sehr wenig
mitleid mit den opfern also sie habe
mitleid mit sich selber ist natürlich
sehr schön weil ich sage wenn wir diese
krieg und das habe ich eben dreimal
gesagt wenn wir das beenden wollen dann
reden wir
wussten dass wir es gab verhandlungen in
der türkei erdogan hat das versuche ich
sage nochmal die europäische
hilfsprogramm euro strafe sich auch
unsere strategie war immer wer den
frieden bin ich nicht will muss
verhandeln dass er das musste aber sie
das verfahren wegen und müssen sie nicht
mehr alles bei putin vor geplant ist das
schon vergessen habe ich mich bei ihnen
waren alle bei mir leute da ich bin ja
nicht bedeuten der märz ist jetzt gerade
da wo man guckt nur mit der zurück kommt
ja und ich sage nochmal wer den krieg
nicht will muss den frieden wollen und
es wird zu viel geredet über helfen
corinne luftsprung das ist kein
bauernkalender sprung in einer alexander
kissler ganz kurz noch mal rein damit
wir alle standpunkte 1 gehört haben herr
kessler sie finden ja gut dass alice
schwarzer diese debatte angestoßen hat
gemeinsam mit den anderen natürlich frau
gehört eben erwähnt wie viele schon
unterzeichnet haben wo sehen sie denn
die lösung oder wo befinden sie sich
jetzt hier in den unterschiedlichen
meinungsspektrum er ist ein
unterschiedliches meinungsspektrum das
ist schon sehr wichtig dass sie das
sagen wir reden eine unterschiedliche
meinungen und wenn man über meinungen
unterschiedliche art rede das ist schon
mal besser als wenn man sich die köpfe
einschlägt man sieht auch jetzt an der
erhitzt zeit jetzt hier gleich parat ich
gewissermaßen explodiert
wie dünn doch die zündschnur wie kurz
die zündschnur geworden ist und mich
erinnern dass teilweise ich würde von
ihrer frage mich nicht drücken aber mich
erinnert die art und weise wie wir eben
debattieren dieser ganzen debatte
teilweise an verwundungen die wir uns
gegenseitig zugefügt haben in der korona
debatte zwei jahre lang ging es auch um
angst da gab es eine gute angst meine
angst vor corona die dann gewisse
verhaltensmaßregeln nahegelegt hat
teilweise staatlich aufoktroyiert es gab
eine schlechte angst die angst vor der
impfung es gab leute die gute argumente
hatten es gab leute die schlechte
argumente hatten und meinungen die vom
mainstream oder von einer
mehrheitsmeinung abwischen wurden lange
nicht als abweichende meinungen gesehen
sondern als moralische defekte dessen
der diese abweichende meinungen äußert
das ist glaube ich eine lehre aus krone
und wir reden teilweise ansatzweise ja
auch schon in der ukraine frage als
hätten wir nichts gelernt oder als wären
wir nicht in der lage etwas zu lernen
aus diesen debatten wir tauschen hier
meinungen aus wir müssen die texte da
wirklich schon ganz genau lesen ich habe
es auch kritische anfragen an diesen
text gar keine frage aber wir müssen
glaube ich die meinung von dem stärker
trennen der sie äußert schreibt mir die
wichtigste lehre zu sein aus der krone
debatte die meinung von dem trennen der
sie äußert ich muss ihnen ehrlich sagen
das ist jetzt eine debatte da kann ich
das lineal anlegen wo ich will und ich
bekomme keine geradeheraus muss ich ganz
klar sagen ich bin selbstverständlich
auch für frieden ich bin aber auch sehr
dafür dass er putin diesen krieg nicht
gewinnt ich bin sehr dafür dass wir der
ukraine nicht sagen welche ziele sie zu
erreichen hat ich bin aber auch sehr
dafür dass wir nicht sagen wir müssen
jetzt fünf sechs sieben jahre lang die
aller schärfsten waffen die wir haben
permanent ohne ansehen der jeweiligen
situation in die ukraine senden das
heißt ich bin wirklich für eine
abrüstung auch in der debatte dass wir
uns mehr in diesen positionen aber ich
muss wirklich sagen mich an inters etwas
an die situation die kennen sie bestimmt
alle im golf von korinth da gab's killer
und carrupt s2 meeresungeheuer und wer
der mann ist links vorbei da wollte man
aufgefressen oder man ist rechner dabei
wurde aufgefressen man kam nicht richtig
durch und meine sorge ist und wenig dass
wir uns hier in dieser debatte in der
wir wirklich nur ein einfaches zeichen
meinungen austauschen und den kopf so
einschlagen als könnten wir hier am
tisch wirklich diese verfahrene
situation genau klären das wäre ein
wichtiger appell lasst uns wirklich
verbal abrüsten und schauen was eine
position ist die wir von unseren eigenen
gewissen seinem gewissen und unserem
eigenen wissen auch verantworten da
würde ich diese debatte ist wie alle
meinungen die in deutschland geäußert
werden für den verlauf des krieges in
der ukraine völlig irrelevant ist ein
argument mehr halt kein geld mehr für
den ausrüster oder abrüsten spielt für
den ausgaben die geschichte keine aber
vielleicht trotzdem